When we think of space,
we may think of the night sky,
space suits, science fiction,
space stations.
With NASA's Artemis mission,
we're going back to the Moon,
for the first time in 50 years,
and this time, with the first
woman on the Moon.
Woo-hoo.
(Cheers and applause)
You may also have heard
that we're planning to send humans
to the surface of Mars,
and the logistics and rocketry
for this long and arduous mission
are going to be figured out eventually,
but shockingly, one of the big problems
we don't have a solution for
is something that most people
don't think about,
and that is food.
What are we going to feed
the astronauts going to Mars?
It turns out it's incredibly complicated.
Before we go there,
I'd like to go over why I am here,
talking to you about this.
I am an industrial designer
and an aerospace architect.
I run a design firm called Nonfiction,
and what we do is that we take
science fiction and we make it real.
It's a real job.
(Laughter)
Just to give you an idea
of the type of work that we do,
here are a few examples.
We take technology and we make it
a natural extension of the human body.
We work with prominent neuroscientists
and design wearables
that help people fall asleep
and stay asleep all night.
We design batteries,
low-cost, for rural Africa.
We build schools that support
neurodiversity and lifelong learning.
We turn humans into superhumans.
So as you can see,
I love working on projects
that make the world a better place
through design.
But most importantly, I love food.
I've been told that food
is my love language.
When I like someone, I feed them.
When I don't like someone ...
well, there's always pizza.
(Laughter)
So when I found out
about this space food competition
put together by NASA,
the Canadian Space Agency
and the Methuselah Foundation,
I knew I had to be part of it.
It's called the Deep Space Food Challenge.
The premise of the challenge
is to figure out what and how
we're going to feed astronauts
on their way to a deep-space mission,
like going to Mars.
So sending living and breathing humans
to Mars or a deep-space mission
is very tricky, as you can imagine.
Going to Mars is going to be
extremely dangerous.
The round trip is going to last
two and a half to three years.
The whole time,
we're going to be bombarded
with life-threatening levels
of space radiation
and we're going to float in microgravity
or stand on the surface of Mars,
experiencing one-third of Earth's gravity.
So it's really uncomfortable
to be up there.
And so all of these conditions,
on top of isolation and stress,
are going to make it very hard
for astronauts
to keep their weight and their health
at optimal levels.
And one of the main culprits
of them losing their weight
is actually unappetizing food.
So imagine having to eat things like these
for three years straight, right?
And looking at the same five people.
That's going to be really hard.
(Laughter)
So what I'd like to go over
is what astronauts eat
aboard the International Space Station,
for example, right now.
So essentially, they have access
to ready-to-eat food,
or food, or freeze-dried food
that you see here,
that's rehydrated with water.
And so it's either goop in a bag,
or if you're feeling fancy,
you can place that goop
in a space tortilla.
(Laughter)
So tortilla is actually
very popular in space,
because it satisfies like bread,
but doesn't crumble
and clog the air-filtration system.
Now, the quality of that tortilla
would make your Mexican grandmother
roll over in her grave,
but it's better than nothing.
By the way, the water that rehydrated
the freeze-dried food
is recycled again and again.
We don't have the luxury
to send all the water that we need.
There's no romantic way of saying it --
it's filtered gray water and pee.
Ew ...
Every once in a while,
astronauts aboard the ISS
have access to fresh produce
and that comes from resupply rockets.
This happens because the Earth is
only 250 miles from the ... space station.
And that's not going to be an option
for people going to Mars,
because that's 300 million miles
away, one way.
They're not going to send, like,
a small rocket with apples and oranges,
just for you.
(Laughter)
So going to Mars is going to be very hard.
It's like hardcore
backpacking in the wild,
except the wild is a cramped space
surrounded by things
that can kill you at any moment.
(Laughter)
So packing food for Mars
is going to require
one ton per person per year.
So if we have a crew
of five, six astronauts,
that’s a lot of weight.
And if there’s one thing
you need to learn about space
is that weight is money.
So what my design team came up with
is this amazing system
called the Space Culinary Lab.
By the way, we won the first phase
of this competition,
and are currently working on prototypes.
(Cheers and applause)
So let's go over the four sections
of this machine.
Step one -- coffee.
In the morning, it's nice to have
a rich, creamy, hot beverage.
A nutritious version of this
is butter coffee.
What would it take for astronauts
to make space butter coffee?
So one of our team members
created this mechanical homogenizer
that breaks down coffee granules,
hot water, collagen and ghee together
and creates this unctuous,
satisfying mouthfeel solution
that is really nice to drink.
What's nice as well
is that it provides you
with omega-3 fatty acids
that can protect your brain
and your heart,
as well as reduce inflammation.
Step two -- snacks.
Microalgae, like spirulina:
research in animals has shown that it can
also boost your immune system,
and help your body from developing cancer.
But the problem is algae is gross.
(Laughter)
It smells funny
and it doesn't taste that great.
So what we can do is to cultivate
a fresh batch aboard the spaceship,
dehydrate the microalgae,
and then mix it with other ingredients.
We can mix it with oats, with nuts,
with powdered berries, with spices.
We can make them sweet,
sour, savory, spicy,
whatever your heart desires.
Oh, and as a bonus,
growing microalgae
absorbs carbon dioxide from the air
and produces oxygen.
In other terms, it's carbon-negative.
So now imagine all of the food systems
that we have on the surface of the Earth.
What if producing food
actually reversed climate change?
Wouldn't that be cool?
Step three -- salad.
When astronauts go
on long missions to space,
one of the things they look forward to
the most when they come back to Earth
is the crunch of a salad.
So salads were designed
to grow with gravity,
so now we're asking it
to grow without gravity.
Well, thankfully, the International
Space Station experiments
have proven that we can
do that with lettuce,
with kale and with other greens.
Let’s give our Mars explorers
a space garden.
It's great to give them
some fresh produce to eat
once in a while
and it's nice for their mental health
to look at a garden once in a while.
Last but not least, step four --
space barbecue.
(Laughter)
So a lot of cultures all over the world
consider grilled protein
a meal centerpiece.
Unfortunately, open fire
is frowned upon in space.
(Laughter)
So we're going to use lasers.
So we're going to take
a piece of chicken, for example,
and we're going to rehydrate it
with a carbohydrate solution.
And then from there, we're going to design
a grill pattern on top
of the chicken, using lasers.
And so the heat, carbohydrate
and protein combination
creates the signature caramelization
that makes barbecued meat
taste and smell so delicious.
With the Space Culinary Lab,
we can imagine all the combinations
of flavors, textures, colors
and rituals, even,
that can come out of this.
What if a Michelin star chef
had access to this kind of system
and created their own spaceborne dishes?
Like, think astrobisque,
floating space-juice caviar,
or space whiskey.
(Laughter)
What is traditionally called
a galley or prep station
is now something that looks and feels
a lot more like a farm-to-table kitchen,
but in space.
What we want to do, really,
is to take all of that space innovation
and bring it back
to other places in space.
We're going to go to the Moon,
we're going to go to Mars,
and what we really want to do at the end
is make space more human.
We want to apply this
to all life-support systems up there.
And bringing all of that technology
back to Earth is nothing new,
by the way.
Like, we've been using
a lot of technologies, every day,
that were invented in space.
For example, solar cells, prosthetics,
water filtration systems, GPS,
wireless communication devices,
even the lens on your camera phone.
So, you know, when we think
about taking all of that technology
that we're developing in space,
what we want to do, really,
is create regenerative ways to replace
nonregenerative agricultural methods
that demand too much resources on Earth.
Every day, there's a lot
of space innovation that's happening,
space that's here to benefit us on Earth.
So one day, not so far in the future,
maybe the way we create food in space
will help us open the door
to become a sustainable
interplanetary species.
Thank you.
(Cheers and applause)